it is Friday again which means you can
get all caught off of the biggest things
that happens in gaming this week right
here let's get that going
bloodborne is coming from the developers
of the souls theory so it's not all that
surprising that it's going to be a
little difficult but apparently even the
developers themselves are having a tough
time playing through the game's hardest
mode blood-borne comes with a new game
plus mode which drastically pumps up the
difficulty after you've completed the
game once perhaps a little too much
blood thorns project director hit attack
in Miyazaki told MCV quote yes there
will be a new game plus mode we're
having trouble beating it though there
is something oddly satisfying about the
creators of the game series that has
elicited so much game of rage getting a
taste of their own medicine Nintendo's
next console is coming and covent and ex
hopefully we'll get a better name when
the console actually releases but it's
Nintendo to adjust your expectations
accordingly the company's chief exec
Satoru Iwata hasn't revealed anything
about the system as yet except for the
fact that it exists and will work with
their new membership service the service
is replacing the recently shut down Club
Nintendo program and will work across a
Nintendo consoles as well as PC
smartphones and tablets speaking of
which Nintendo also announced they were
going to develop mobile games in
collaboration with publishers DNA
their existing IP this weekend cheap
stuff if you're a fan of trade ins you
can get a ps4 for just 225 bucks which
is pretty sweet gamestop have a deal
going where you can trade in a ps3 or an
xbox 360 to get 175 bucks credit toward
the purchase of a four-hundred-dollar
standard ps4 system your ps3 will need
to be at least 120 gigabytes and your
360 needs to be at least two hundred and
fifty gigabytes on top of that you still
need to have all the components and the
system needs to be in working order if
you can meet those requirements though
and your last gen console is gathering
dusk anyway you can take advantage of
the offer which will actually land you
with the ps4 and a copy of the Last of
Us remastered there's all ps4 is now
come coupled with the game GTA heists
finally launched this week and brought
with it a particularly difficult
challenge of the internet being what it
is one crew managed to pull it off the
criminal masterminds challenge requires
a team to complete all heist setup and
finales in order at the same time and
without losing any lives the reward for
such a feat is a cool 10 million any
game but and this week for further GTA
players completed it earning themselves
the cash plus another two million in
other bonuses although considering the
state of heists that launch they
probably should have been awarded two
million just for getting onto the server
simultaneously one player coin walk said
the challenge it was the most fun I've
had in GTA online ever and one of the
most stressful challenges I've ever
experienced in a video game
finally this week kajima drama is off
the charts with the music thing to
seemingly not going well between Kaname
and developer Kojima Productions Konami
have been removing Kojima Productions
branding from all official Metal Gear
art as well as their social media
according to an inside source kajima
will be leaving the company when his
contract ends in December along with the
senior staff allegedly Konami have been
edging out Kajima and the studio
altering the company structure so that
their contractors instead of full-time
employees and restricting their
influence and presents surrounding the
release of metal gear solid 5 the
phantom pain Kaname is also in the
process of removing kajima from their
board of executives let me know down in
the comments what you cared about this
week and what you think to do mr.
Parcher will mean for metal gear and
styling skills this week on site I give
you awesome [ __ ] game alternatives to
battlefield hardline on ships Skyrim
mods takes on warcraft active death
winged dragon and lucy wraps up Metal
Gear story on in two minutes thanks for
joining me again this week as always let
me know what you cared about [ __ ]
yourselves a great weekend and I'll
catch you again on Monday
you